Luke 8
44-48 yeah Luke 84
4448 No actually that's in Mark yeah
it's in Mark 5 and it's also in Luke 8
yes where the woman touched them and he
goes who touched
me yeah okay
now a person can ask questions either
because he's ignorant or he can ask
questions either to confront you and
have you to come forward and acknowledge
and confess right
yes for example and this is you'll find
this in the Quran as well but in the
Hadith but put that aside God says to
Cain in Genesis 4:7 I'm sorry yes
earlier Genesis 4:10 he goes where's
your brother he goes how do I know am I
My Brother's Keeper he goes what have
you done the blood of your brother cries
out to me so God asked Cain where's your
brother knowing that Cain had killed
Abel right yes so why did he ask him
in order to confront him to show you how
wicked and evil he is he thinks he can
lie to me and get away with it and he
doesn't repent
right yes now even in Mark 5 if you had
read it care make you realize that he
has sinned yes not only realize sin to
show you how evil and wicked Cain is
that when I ask him about his brother he
thinks he can lie and cover up his crime
because that tells tells you that Cain
thinks that God doesn't see everything
and know
everything because if Cain knew God
knows everything and sees everything it
would be stupid on his part to say how
do I know am I my brother's
keeper because he would know that God
already knows
right yes he already know so God is
doing that to show you because this is
going to be recorded by W inspiration
look how evil this man is that even when
I confront him he thinks he can cover
his crime and get away with it because
he thinks I don't see and know all
things so he didn't ask because God
didn't know
right yes even in that chapter if you
read it it's in Mark 5 it's in Matthew 9
it's Luke 8 same story didn't even the
disciples get astonished saying all this
crowd pressing in on you and you ask who
touched
you there's an entire crowd touching you
Jesus and you're wondering who touched
you who didn't touch you so then that
tells you Jesus knew something happened
right for him to ask who touched me
right yeah because he knew that's why he
asked the question ah so why did he ask
if he knew that this woman touched him
and then healing power came out of his
body into her and to heal her why do you
think he asked
her because what did she do huh like who
does my clothes he he asked yeah so why
when everyone was touching his clothes
right then even disciples say all this
crowd this this throng they're all
touching you what do you mean who
touched you who didn't touch you so that
means Jesus knows something's happening
right something like changed like yeah
so why is he asking think about it
because she came stealthily
secretly didn't want to be known she
wanted to remain hidden touch then took
off right so why do you think then Jesus
asked her
I I believe there's a deep wisdom well
don't no think about it okay she if you
read it carefully she goes if only I
Touch the Hem of His Garment I'll be
healed so she knew he can heal her and
she had that much Faith but she did it
secretly right touched and took off
wanted to do it in secret hiding and
hide
right yes so then now make the
connection who touched my cloak why do
you think he's asking because he answer
to confess and acknowledge the miracle
and give testimony and not hide
it so like just just trying to prove
that he is the Son of God like in other
words why are you going to hide what God
has done for you you should go around
and proclaim the goodness of God and how
much he loves you and what he has done
for you this is similar to even in Mark
5 the demoniac earlier remember the man
what did Jesus say to that man earlier
he says go to your people and tell them
all that the Lord has done for you and
he went around telling him all that
Jesus had
done right in Mark 5 that
demoniac
yes
right yeah and so what did he say go
announce all the good that God has done
for you because when God does something
for you you don't hide it you then
declare it to the world in order to give
witness to how good God is how merciful
and loving he is and how much he loves
us okay so uh in Mark 6 verse number
five so like you know the words like he
could not do any Miracles except lay his
hand on a few sick people and heal them
about that so notice he did heal people
so what does it mean he could not heal
people you just said the you finished
the verse he could could not heal people
except some few so doesn't mean he could
not heal because he didn't have the
ability you just read it like yeah read
it again so like like he could not do
any Miracles there except lay his hand
on a few sick people and heal them okay
so that tells you he could heal and he
did heal
right yes so what does it mean he could
not heal that means he didn't have the
ability
well you just finished the verse of
course he had the ability because he
healed people and healed some sick among
them
right oh yes it's right in front of you
so what do you mean he could not heal
finish it no I mean he could not do any
any Miracles there and yet he did finish
it yeah except his leg except his hands
on F isn't that a
miracle that's also a miracle but why
does the verse also say you need to go
deeper what does he mean could not means
I don't have the ability or could not
means because of your resistance and
refusing to acknowledge me you left me
no choice but not to do any Miracles so
what's the meaning in the
context can I explain the verse move for
me yeah it's right in front of you who's
he talking to people his own Hometown
who are offended by him and thought he
was out of his mind right
yes right so what does it mean he could
not meaning he didn't have the ability
or he could not because of their lack of
faith and resistance they left them no
choice but not to do any miracles for
them
oh okay you got it now the light switch
went on